da ist es wieder das Gespenst des
Rechtspopulismus in Europa schon wieder
und es ist gekommen um zu
bleiben 35
[Applaus]
Sitze wir sind die größte Partei der
Niederlande und ich sage der W hat
gesprochen der W hat nun endlich
gesprochen haben die Nase voll wir haben
es satt und ich werde dafür sorgen dass
die Niederlande wieder groß
werdent wilders hat bei den Wahlen in
den Niederlanden mit seiner pww die
Mehrheit errungen jetzt will er
regieren ich werde dafür sorgen dass die
Niederlande wieder den Niederländern
gehört dass der asylzunami begrenzt wird
dass die Menschen wieder mehr Geld im
portmonna haben
seit Jahrzehnten ist re Wilders der
ewige Wiedergänger der niederländischen
Politik oft totgesagt doch todgesagte
leben länger selbst am rechten Rand
jeder Wähler und jede Wählerin in
Holland hatte ausreichend Zeit zu wissen
wer und wessen geisteskind hert Wilders
ist jetzt haben sie ihn gewählt einen
Pöbler Hetzer und Spalter einen
antieuropäer der vom Ende der EU vom
NATO austritt und einer eigenen Währung
träumt niederländische goldlden mit
seinem eigenen Konterfei
darauf und heute will Brüssel wie Sie
wissen uns mit Einwanderern aus der
Dritten Welt
überschwemmen hauptsächlich aus
islamischen Ländern sie will diese
Einwanderer über die ganze Europäische
Union verteilen und das meine Freunde
wird eine
Katastrophe die EU und die Ausländer
hert wilders hat klare Feindbilder und
macht auch keinen Hel daraus
wollt ihr in dieser Stadt und in den
Niederlanden mehr oder weniger
Marokkaner weniger
weniger dann werden wir das
Regeln im aktuellen Wahlkampf wählte er
gemäßigte Töne gab sich staatsmännisch
wurde vom Wilders zum Milders wie die
Presse nicht ohne Häme erkannte doch die
Frage bleibt warum wählt warum will ein
Volk einen Rechtspopulisten als
politisch Führer und wie wird die
vermeintlich etablierte Politik nun
reagieren will das Gegnerin die
rechtsliberale dan jeschilg r die
vielbeschworene Brandmauer schon vor der
Wahl ein Schloss eine Koalition nicht
explizit
aus die rechte Europas gratuliert schon
mal verbundene Grüße aus Frankreich aus
Ungarn aus Italien und aus Deutschland
wird die Wahl Wilders Schule machen die
rechte Europas jedenfalls hofft schon
heute auf den nächsten politischen
Höhenflug der niederländische Journalist
und Autor rob saelberg ist aktuell
Korrespondent der Tageszeitung der
Telegraph in Berlin von dort aus hat er
die Wahl in seiner Heimat natürlich
gestern genaustens beobachtet guten
Abend Herr sabelberg sein Sie herzlich
gegrüßt für uns im Ausland schien Gert
Wilders über viele Jahre quasi von der
politischen Bühne verschwunden zu sein
jetzt ist er plötzlich wieder da und sie
sagen er plane eine Art Kulturrevolution
falls er wirklich regieren sollte wie
säe die denn aus ja die sieht so aus
dass er uns natürlich Journalisten
JournalistInnen Abschaum nennt er möchte
eigentlich dann öffentlich rechtlichen
Rundfunk abschaffen das steht auch in
seinem Wahlprogramm was ja von dem
Viertel der Wähler gefolgte wurde also
Richter sind nicht seine größte Freunde
er wurde ja auch verurteilt wegen
gruppenbeleidigung einer Minderheit der
Marokkaner in der Niederlande also er
will wirklich eine Kulturrevolution also
man kann auchch sagen nexit z.bel dass
die Niederlande Europäische Union
verlassen also all diese Sachen
deuten natürlich darauf dass sich
einiges ändern könnte in in den Hag in
in meiner Heimat und will das ja der
würde eigentlich gern die die Axt
ransetzen nur er ist mit seiner Partei
nicht ganz alleine er bräuchte natürlich
auch Partner
Koalitionspartner um seine
Ideen umzusetzen und kulturell kann man
sehen dass ich manchmal orientiert sich
eher bei Vladimir Putin oder bei Donald
Trump als bei vielleicht vielen anderen
Niederländern er hat immerhin die
meisten Stimmen bekommen das heißt ja
dass viele Niederländerinnen und
Niederländern seine Axt gut fenden warum
warum genau
jetzt ich denke er spricht die die
Sprache des des Volkes also er ist einen
sehr erfahrener Politiker kommt
eigentlich aus der
rechtskonservativen
VVD die Volkspartei für Freiheit und
Demokratie die in den letzen Jahen mit
premier Mark
rüte der ministerpresidenten gestellt
hat also er war ja auch mal bfreundet
mit Mark Rutte aber dann vor 20 Jahren
haben sich die Wege getrennt und man
kann eigentlich sehen dass
das er so ein bisschen Einzelgänger
geworden ist und warum das populär ist
er erer spricht die wirkliche Probleme
an die auch viele Menschen haben
Wohnungsnot
Inflation Themen in den Niederlanden
also nicht so sehr die
große internationale politiek sonder
eher so Benzinpreise wo können die
älteren Menschen gut versorgt werden was
kosten die Sachen im Supermarkt also
diese Themen hat er angesprochen und er
hat ein bisschen den den linken Weg den
linkspopulismus gewäht wobei eigentlich
für Rechtspopulismus berühmt geworden
ist wenn er sich also jetzt wieder
darauf konzentriert Niederlande vor
allem für die Niederländer und
Niederländerinnen zu gestalten und
vielleicht die EU zu verlassen was
bedeutet das dann für die EU und für
Europa ja das ist natürlich ein ein
wegruf also ich denke die Alarmglocken
haben geläutet in Brüssel vielleicht
auch in Berlin da wollte man sich bei
der Bundesregierung noch nicht so ganz
dazu äußern aber ein nexit natürlich von
einem Gründungsmitglied der Europäischen
Union ja das wäre natürlich ein ein
Albtraum
man sieht aber dass sich in den letzten
Jahren ganz viel verändert hat also Frau
Meloni regiert schon in Italien also in
Skandinavien haben sich die Sachen
verändert also Dänemark bisschen
strenger in Polen z.B waren
die die Konservativen an der an der an
der Macht und man sieht in vielen Teilen
Europas hat es Regierung gegeben oder
gibt es immer noch die sozusagen ein
nicht sehr proeuropäische Weg
eingeschlagen haben und ich glaube her
will bdient sich immer am Vorbild Ungarn
also Viktor Orban ist ja auch ein Freund
von ihm hat ihm schon empfangen also die
Ehefrau von gertwers kommt auch aus
Ungarn und sieht eigentlich das
ungarische Modell
m eigentlich a ein Modell auch für die
Niederlande wobei natürlich das
Nachbarland von Deutschland sehr Export
orientiert und sehr offen ist auch von
der Wirtschaft und von den Menschen her
von daher wird es für die nächste Zeit
sehr spannend wie auch Brüssel damit
umgeht ja wenn sozusagen dieses
Gründungsmitglied der Europäischen Union
ein etwas anderen etwas mehr rechten Weg
rechteren Weg einschlägt Gert wild das
ist nicht nur ein Freund Russland
sondern auch vor allem
Israels auch als Kooperationspartner
sozusagen gegen den Islam was hat die
Eskalation im Nahen Osten jetzt genau
darauf für einen
Einfluss also das ist natürlich ein ein
äh ja ein Albtraum für die Menschen in
Israel in der Region
MW das ist immer schon sehr verbunden
mit Israel er hat da in seinen jungen
Jahren im kibut hat er gearbeitet und er
sieht
eigentlich seine Position an der Seite
von Israel bestätigt durch den jzigen
Krieg also er war schon immer sehr stark
gegen den Islam also damals bei seinuch
und seine Arbeit dort aber sieeh die
Islam den Islam auch nicht aus eine
Religion sondern eher aus eine Ideologie
und er hat darüber einen Film gemacht
nachdem der Filmemacher Theo von Goch
ermordet wurde von einem Islamisten in
Amsterdam das war 2004 danach hat er den
Film Fitna gemacht und das hat ihm eine
Fatwa eingebracht also er wurde zur
Persona n grata und seitdem lebt dieser
Politiker dieser extreme Politiker aus
der Niederlanden unter Polizeischutz
also er hat auch das öfter Berlin
besucht
die AFD aber auch Veranstaltungen hier
gemacht in Deutschland und auch da muss
er immer von der Polizei auch von der
niederländischen Polizei beschützt
werden weil sein Leben in Gefahr ist und
er hat sich natürlich dadurch in in eine
Art Sackgasse bewogen weil seine
bewegungsfreiit einfach
sehr gering seitdem ist sie haben schon
gesagt es ist alles andere als
ausgemacht ob er regieren wird ich danke
Ihnen sehr für das Gespräch wir sind
gespannt auf die weiteren
Entwicklung
gerne